you know back from New York back from
Vegas doesn't have coffee chin oh yeah
we don't have any wish I did though I
told you I wanted to get coffee
they said I'm good I've never heard you
say that before well I had a quad shot
latte before my other show so I don't
[ __ ] my pants quad shot and did you have
coffee before that too I am three no
four cups before though you'll put it
down well we could bet five something
like drink it
yeah you're drinking you drink I'm five
I work out at 7:00 I only go to one
place I told you with coffee right where
they have a $38 cup of coffee
who Oh place called funnel mill what's
it up it's in Santa Monica it's in Santa
Monica and it there's an iced latte
there that well it tastes the way coffee
smells yeah an iced latte
yeah that's $7 worth it I drive across
town to get toys okay not a big deal
yeah but what's the $38 one it's a very
special bean and they sell it for $100
elsewhere Oh hold up as fun as this the
Japanese now that yes Santa Monica yes
but the studio's right better yeah all
right get the iced americano please they
calibrate their water it's cool pH of
say now calm down
no no all this has been there for I know
it is and now I think you're like
breaking ground I'm breaking stuff me
Tony's always have cup hey Johnny come
lately you don't have you Tony okay you
have the rare siphon coffee yeah that's
what you do at the Japanese place yeah
it's true they're Chinese they're from
Taiwan please I don't think so no
actually I thought there were Japanese
too turns out you're sure I want yeah I
asked them that place is very Japanese
it's very Japanese just in a Chinese
Chinese yeah a lot of lovely green yeah
a lot of green tea I got the Kopi Luwak
coffee which for $100 the place is good
though I could use something I don't
listen I don't give a [ __ ] where it's
from I would use the coffee and the the
shitty green room yeah you like your
coffee
Jeb like I just like it black well they
serve it black but it's like blind guys
dude you lots of notes I want to go get
the $38 a cup of coffee just to see what
the [ __ ] they're talking about
oh we're was oh no uh what's God
Alfred's has the $20 latte
oh it's make us all rich No hell no it's
made with some special
almond milk yeah [ __ ] off yeah [ __ ] off
for their $20 pretty sure it's the $20
like that yeah black conferences back
from Vegas where where everyone is
hustling ever it's a hustle all the way
across the board I think just the girls
are hustling right no I think the guys I
think everybody's got an agenda feel it
from the guy just everybody everybody's
working it's like I feel like literally
I feel like everyone is lying about
everything I feel like everyone's lying
about everything and it's fine because
you when you go therefore we had a great
meal we had a great time great show by
the way that was a fun fun show how
about JJ Walker fantastic we'll get to
him he's a good he's a very good sort of
segue because JJ's been on the road
well since 1968 and he hit us with that
the first thing that Jed
JJ dynamite that on my Walker who's been
doing stand-up and been performing six
years since well yeah he's 72 years old
been doing since he's 20 yeah so you're
talking about you know 40 years 50 years
no I'm a long dynomite yeah and so so
dynamite was only four years ago the
first thing he said is he goes now you
guys are the comedy duo and we said well
we're separate acts but he said mm-hmm
now hmm I know everybody I know
everybody so when I saw your name I was
like yes exactly did hey so Brennan I
was like we were like does that good
thing yeah yeah it's like Oh yikes you
and I go yikes when somebody's not that
good yeah years so he goes hey I know
everybody too and I've seen it but then
and he said it again he goes but I saw
you guys and I was like hey I saw this
joke I was like so what does that mean
you don't know us I guess
and he goes brain and Schwab y'all bring
you up I was in the job job I go he'll
definitely Schwab God funny he do this
thing hey man y'all these reality shows
man I'll tell you what that [ __ ]
Jersey Shore and my
right honey boo-boo he did have dated
remedies but he had good energy I'll
tell you I can't wait like that dress
the park to come out man I've been
waiting then dinosaur but me and me and
J actually laughs he was funny yeah he's
fun he's he's hurt he's a great
performer but so to hum a little uh a
window ah you're opening for it um
seeing this right okay cool see this is
what he's getting cuz he got he got
Brendan's name wrong so but before that
JJ said I got t-shirts and I got I got
signed autographs and I also have
pictures and I got CDs CDs coming free
so Brennan he is now Brendon Schwab so
Brendan goes to say shakes hand I guess
he was joking right guys don't touch me
don't touch me brother and it burns like
oh that was because I saw him like pull
it girl on stage you went to and he goes
no turd laughing yeah and he goes don't
touch me and he walked away I was like
that's weird
and then so um the Brendan's first joke
is whoa CDs huh yeah I guess I'm in an
episode of Hot Tub Time Machine so
phillium in hot tub times make sure you
get this make sure you jday CDs in the
back [ __ ] nice guy though but he's
he's that that 250 days in the road for
450 years Lebanon bro it's weathered and
so and I'm sure they'll say the same
thing about me when I'm 72 well they're
saying it now they are saying it now but
do you notice that in Vegas what you'll
see is like because I see all these
people hustling girls the girls it's all
one big house talking get your dick
sucked anyone you see if you fly in for
the weekend my your work ma get your
money and leave money get money and
leave hottest girls in the planet now
they don't save their money typically
typically they don't save their money
financial advisor I'm trying to bust
nuts girl that's it because they figure
that they I understand but they think
the trains gonna keep going but you know
how that ends you know how that story
ends and what I think is interesting is
in in Vegas you can see the people that
have never left the girls that came
there and somehow got stuck there but
now that desert air the smoke but their
skin looks like they got I've seen
better skin on a rhinoceros it's tough
man but also it's like it's so short
sight it's almost like professional
sports a little bit like bottle service
girls so I have some friends working the
ball service industry
they are gorgeous and they make so much
money but then actually you know you're
37 38 you might have a house or
something like that but then once the oh
I'm sorry they don't oh no there's new
crop of girls coming so 37 38 see ya
because your lifestyle really haven't
found a man you don't have a ton of
savings for you getting all this cash so
you're often lying to all the men so
they don't nobody but not not even the
lying part that's whatever some of them
are actually really good people so but a
lot of it you just don't it's it's so
one-sided yet you get done you've
nothing to fall back on your looks or
making the money you're like dude I'm 38
and all I know how to do is grab giant
bottles of Courvoisier so to make it
[ __ ] rain on God it's like yeah then
the smart ones hustle get their money
and bounce when they're still in their
prime yes but even the beauty even like
the showman like even JJ the Vegas act
it it's an it's a Vegas like Liberace
ham David you know Copperfield like hey
yeah yeah yeah it's like this funny
sense of security and the girls are all
together so they're all kind of having a
good time at that point they're there at
that age they get so much attention
they're making so much money if you're
not saving that and putting it towards
something Lamar so I've known something
yeah there's these beasties they start
their own businesses that's my thing if
you're gonna hustle no problem I love
you for us like just just make sure
you're building something that you can
fall back on when you're 38 and the
music stops because the music oh the
smart ones
someone's I know buy a property that's
have like four properties there you go
that's what you want to do yeah there's
some smart ones then I'll see there's
get a nest egg majority of dum-dums yeah
get a nest egg that JJ walk was funny
that was fun
he was he kept going like this he kept
showing me pictures he goes I write with
these guys they worked with me I don't
know if you've seen this out if you've
heard these guys they go oh that's Jay
Leno and I don't know if you heard I'm
the funny part though what kind of phone
with it oh yeah he it was the muscle
it's cool it was original iPhone you
couldn't see I was like that black and
white is that pig cleaner he's great
he's great
how about uh you had the most busted
shoes we've ever seen sameen Jay took
you to Gucci get shoes
you took off your boots and that's the
hardest I've ever seen Jay left Jay
laughed so hard I had black shoes on I
bought in Canada and how long did you
buy those probably five years ago oh my
god they were I never wore them and I
found them in my trunk in my secret
compartment on my trunk in case we run
out of shoes and I go I'm gonna put
these on I was like you know they go
well with my jeans there was just
straight black dress shoes oh but
somebody took them off and they were I I
was in Gucci and I said let's I'm just
gonna go look at Gucci cuz they want to
look at Gucci I'm not gonna go buy I
don't buy Gucci stuff you do know they
had those Chelsea boots they're good
sprays you wear them to date then they
went home they look sweet dude how about
the one black dude who tried on the pair
shoes oh my god forgot about him ah I
forgot about him he puts a lot he's like
loud you know dude and he puts them on
what do you do so what oh god damn I'm
telling you in front everyone goes god
damn god I got $700 Sudama and then
Brian goes that dance she's gonna you
gonna get him Gus I'm just gonna try
them on I just gonna try them on
I'm trying on Bob my mom he was there
with his girl was there and she was just
sitting and he had sweatpants on like
really old shitty busted sweatpants
socks that were kind of dirty and and
and slides that he has socks in and then
the pants were pulled down over these
underwear he's been wearing since
nineteen you know 91 and then he had
kind of a real busted Jersey I mean
shirt yeah it's a terrible Gucci
sneakers that couldn't been more the
only one made him more loud of is if
there was a siren on that fur alibi and
siren yeah and he did this thing where I
thought he was having with others joke
well I also thought he was having some
kind of an episode just seizure yeah it
didn't look like his he went oh and he
started pushing his he was like don't
god you know I dusted it scared me at
first I said what the [ __ ] going on
what's this guy doing here he's having a
diabetes no no I got to get these yep
and I had to say something I go you're
excited about those shoes man I'm
excited I think you're gonna buy me this
about try my little bomb
I am winner
I'm winner shot my butt yep I
window-shopping I got it was awesome
hopefully he's wearing those as we speak
and then he bought them and that's where
you want to spend your money now he was
Gucci shoes are a good place to put your
hard-earned cash because they appreciate
and value you know some good shoes
though dude good shoes is right this is
right and then we saw and then a guy
walked by me he was on the plane with us
and he walked by I asked you a question
you said it's over there and he was in
shorts and I went I look at his body I
go get bigger legs when I'm on the plane
yeah bigger legs dude can't pick legs I
was like look at that guy looks like a
[ __ ] nukes strong guys he's got
strong legs
Brennan goes oh you don't know who that
is that was the first-round draft pick
Heisman Trophy winner sake one a year
Penn State he was like that guy looks at
sweating kind of it looks like kind of
strong I was needing a ride home so we
walked out the other way talking after I
saw you huh and then he's like a weird
you know where'd we get our bags at man
do you hear what I'm like I don't know
and he's there ops came in town train he
was like three bags he's getting his own
roll away on a bike did you want to toss
these in my truck but I want to be weird
yeah but but he knew who you were yeah
but also like his manager and agent do
better man like that guy's such a freak
I helped him out where was he going
I don't know prior to work out somewhere
but he had all his [ __ ] and he's like
you know he's like outside like looking
for the thing to put his I'm like he got
how do you not have any help man yeah I
was gonna help making real money he
signed a big contract right alvaro key
contract ready I'm sure Nikes paid him
he's a freak he's amazing mazing
creature amazing yeah amazing human
being all different uh chin will happen
even cars Ford so real quick since our
stereotype this is just like our to
Asian employees yeah one racked last
week the other lotta guts car stolen mmm
Auto is stolen I recall this morning
this bro I'll be late my car got stolen
take it from there chin go what happened
I didn't realize it wasn't stolen so I
actually went to the police department
and filed a police report and as I'm
following up cause I went downstairs to
the front desk and I said my car's
missing did you did anyone toe a car for
whatever reason they're like there's no
toe slip
in front I'm like well my car's gone so
I'm gonna stole my car I'll go make sure
don't delete this footage you know I'd
like a 24 hour footage that runs through
make sure don't delete it I have to file
a police report so I called the police
department three different ones because
Ellie I guess have different parts of LA
nightmare
right and they said that I have to go
into the to the station so I went to the
station started feeling it out and then
my apartment called me said they've not
seen any tow trucks come in since the
time I got there right which is 7 p.m. 6
p.m. yesterday until this morning so
then I was like ok what happened and he
goes you probably parked it in the wrong
area so what happened was we just got
back from Vegas I was super tired my
car's parked in the 5th floor of the
structure and you've been living on how
long how long is it in like six months
ok little fly but scary ok ok you've
been parked it's exactly when you go
through the structure everything is the
same right there same so I parked on the
fourth floor instead of the fifth floor
in the exact same species not saying I
didn't check the other I was panting
because those were also way to work I
don't want to be late to work right got
that headache you've had for two years
no two months that is your headache on
no it's it's not as bad right now but
it's everyday you have everyday and it
stays with you
yeah and have you gone to a doctor 27th
my first appointment was today 27th so
you're gonna wait 10 days cause action
that was early as I can get it all my
what kind of doctor are you going to
Heiser no but are you going to eight an
internist said well you have to see a
general then yeah I think I have to go
to must see my primary care physician or
a neurologist immediately first you have
chin Kaiser or whatever so you could
secure ologist because that's who I'm
sure they'll refer me if they see
something bad I'm sure after you tests
they're gonna give you an MRI I'm sure I
have to I'm pretty sure after your test
again I've done those before when I was
a kid so my shirt good
I had like super bad headaches on as a
kid oh you did there's no and then what
they find when your kid nothing
yeah so it didn't they went away
striction of the blood vessels I think I
know a lot about it's [ __ ] listen to
me it's probably the constriction of
blood vessels that I felt better after
you said it's probably not a brain tumor
I actually felt a lot better it's not
brain to know yeah Jaden telling us you
have a tomb of Jesus Christ on us hey
James like Brian that one person said
you did this I know it was like I'm like
what are you doing I was like I was like
that's a good fuse what she did say that
I know I was like that's impossible cuz
she's a good friend of mine I would
never do that a lot
she was a little office so weird what he
said that I went what I think is
drinking the whole trip because then we
are you sipping all funny then with
Chinese like definitely have a - how
long like a month - non-stop and Jay
goes that's a brain typical yes he goes
that's a brain tumor and you go what
girl look at me he was for a month for a
mom that's a brain tumor because what
else could it be I'm like hey hey hey
off this trip it's not though thanks
dude I definitely you checked out change
nothing cuz you're you've you need to
take more kratom you're probably going
through it's not great diction there's
oh no no you brain but you're definitely
probably I would assume chin it has
something to do with I bet you they tell
you to wean off the create them here's
what I also suspect you're gonna lie and
say you're not taking create them all
Tom but I don't know what it is no and
they're gonna tell you to stop taking
they don't know what it is until you
stop taking yeah yeah I'm sure no anyway
doctors know about creative yeah yeah
maybe I kind of feel like they don't but
the general doctors have you looked up
sewed up headaches
no no not kratom well let's look it up
for a second no it has everything has
every side effect on there so you can go
through it was gonna have it you don't
want to bro Sciences chin now just go to
the doc do you want to go to the lots of
the general doctors are the worst
because they're very general I get I get
vanilla I had the most depressing
override of all time when I left you
really of all time we had a great
weekend and you can have and it takes
very little time to get to my place I
get in and the guy has he's very
overweight rather gray but he's he's all
great but he's seven years younger than
me so I look at him and he says I said
and I go I don't know what to say I
don't like is it gonna rain it was keep
sweat threatening to
yeah yeah yeah yeah I go cool oh uh hey
see yeah they shut this area off he knew
the airport really well how long you
been driving over I guess a lot longer
than I care to admit
I was like okay what else do you do he
goes well right now I'm trying to get
into computer programming but I'm
terrible at networking I was like Oh
didn't know the computer programmer
ahead required networking so much I was
like right so cool and he goes but just
I'm just resorted unless he pulls out a
book and it was goes self-help you know
and you're Robin stellar who that kind
of stuff it was it was a an old book and
I went one of the first self-help books
and I went hmm
I said thinking Grow Rich and I go
thinking grow it take okay I go now you
know me you you'll shut your mouth I
have to try to get in there and help
somebody like you have headache I got to
tell you about your blood vessels I got
I got a I got a help the guy I see I
called a waste of time
no no and you're right and you're right
but I never learn so I go he goes well
starting to start first I want to just
try to start losing weight and I go oh
my god nutrition you can't print talk to
the nutrition expert examine cousin act
Oh more if we give you some well exactly
not the other thing let me get long
story short he's on the podcast
Wednesday dude long time he's a good
friend of mine but I just said that he
is a he's worth it as soon as I hear
that I see red eagle
but it was so funny because I I say to
him I started with my nutrition no no
and he goes he hits me with this I go
what are you eating and he goes I'm
eating only I have just some fruit in
the morning and then I have a sandwich
and then I have a salad I go I go that's
a lie I said what else you didn't go
that's it I take it 69 and we're going
to the doctor I figure out why can't
lose weight and I said well how is your
energy level is you know that's the
thing I've always had no energy ever
since I was a kid so I'm like okay the
only thing I might go so as we're
driving we're almost home and I'm like I
can't I gotta get out of here and then I
go he has he goes oh and the first thing
it was he goes he picks me
I got Kate traveling and he goes right
you coming or going I was like
um well we're driving away from the
airport so obviously you're out of your
mind but no no maybe you thought you
landed and then you were going somewhere
you know like you're from Boston Lane
but he picked me up at arrival he picked
me up from the airport and taking me
home
we don't know it's your house you're
gonna see a girl right okay but still
you pick me up and you're taking me away
from the airport that would usually mean
if you're taking me toward the airport
it be yeah you know it was just so then
he goes like this and that's how I
started I started to give him advice ago
well maybe try to do this and he goes
yeah the thing is I had a fatal heart
attack oh yeah when I was three years
ago when he was 42 geez man and I said
why goes the the vessels in my heart are
curved and so junk gets caught in the
mean fat yeah and I just want this I go
I just went like this as I got we got
there and I went like this I go well I
wish you I wish you the best I get out
like I'm a blackjack dealer I just go
like this
thank you for your time anyone they
switch I still think well you don't you
just go right to your phone no it's a
waste time yeah yeah no I wonder how
much time I've studied on my phone I
stare out the window pretend I don't
hear yeah I I've spent a lot of time in
my life trying to I okay it's the waste
of time this I'm it's I'm like you were
the five minute ride with that uber
driver my goodness so here's my question
to you here's my question and I was
thinking about what I've done
no here's my question photoshopped out
of it so you have a grown man who is
down how old let's say he's 45 he was 45
days 30 no let's say 45 let's stick to
45 Brian let's call it what it is he's
45
uber to know is there anything a man can
say to another man on that ride anything
that can make a difference or change his
life is your name Tony Robbins no is
your name Tony Robbins Bryan Callen oh
do you have it all figured out huh no
then what are you doing I'm sorry
is your name pony ride but dope but
isn't there have you ever or isn't there
a way for somebody to say one thing to
you that changes your perspective on
yourself and gives you some inspiration
is it possible 45 years old
if you round that I picked up in the car
to give me in spot so no it's wrong it's
that ship has sailed
that ship has sailed right now he sat
there long enough looking at all you can
do right I'm numb he's lying in the lane
how about if you're 25 oh for sure yeah
yeah then then you can make a difference
I mean people can hear something that
can change their coz I had a guy say you
think of strength is you're trying to be
a dog when you're a cat like sometimes
you can you can be redefined and you can
kind of stop trying to be this versus
woohoo you hadn't know the dry stuff so
he's weird man I had a kid I would a
bunch of artwork and this guy's
assistant dropped it off and he's young
man 19 I think and he dropped it off and
he goes [ __ ] man and you decide you know
he's young because he talks like this
hashtag goals hashtag inspo that's why I
got in support from I've never heard of
a farmer's tech goals how about hashtag
in SPO that car yours went that's mine
minutes he's God dang this is crazy
makers ah and then he drops off my stuff
I'm helping carry aeneas what advice
would you give man 19 you know my
brother does this something in finance
and you know I'm gonna start and he's
talking about this app because I'm gonna
make money and all that stuff and I said
the only advice I can give you it's the
only thing I I can't give you much
anything essays do not do anything for
money then you're gonna be fun yes
that's never that's good advice and what
that's it but my larger crush I can't
spell but my larger question a second
only comes to Bryan and Brin for inspo
yeah but my larger question is that I
feel like there's nothing like you
either are motivated to find inspiration
or you're not right so like magnifying I
was talking to my my sister about this
like the [ __ ] was I say that what was
the thing but I remember saying I've
always been motivated like no matter
what I even when I was a kid I always
had a plan I would always have these
these plans so so if it was like to get
a black belt and you know Taekwondo or
become a really good wrestler you know I
always had these accomplishments until I
even though they didn't make money but
by the time I was 18 I was about money
but I'd always know we'd always been
motivated to get something done like two
I'd have a goal well then you got a said
brother know what I'm trying to say is
that there might be a personality type
you're either
I told you and when Mark Marino's goes
hey I need you to talk to the guys about
coming to practice all time I went
alright and now hey Mark once we talk to
you guys it's too late if you have to
hear from me they have to show up for
practice every day you're to like stop
now and go get a job at stop there you
go Marko's Jesus so it someone has to be
that's so true dude that's so [ __ ]
true it's the same thing as like you see
people who have these goals but they do
nothing to get there and it's always
like some yeah
I waste my time on it yeah yeah who was
your biggest influence growing up uh uh
Tony Robbins no come on I don't know man
there's so many so really zoom your dad
no not I mean too many tipping that dad
everyone no but I mean I get from
everywhere did you ever see when did you
do you remember when you were like I
want to or would you just always had it
oh is that it huh yeah no there's that
one person a ton how shy you inspo how
fun is that
hashtag house Coles has tagged in Spa ho
house tag House Calls
hash hash starter house calls like he
wants my house house house goals hash
tag house goals hash tag inspo had a
backwards hat on like it was like if you
booked him a movie like dude it's too
on-the-nose for a nine year or nineteen
yo he get tires whoa my man before it
was so funny
hey he's awesome though hashtag inspo
and nobody ever does that about my Tesla
there's so many Tesla's you know I do
the new Prius yeah um yeah man how about
your boy how about your boy who got you
your your car and he's talked to me
about Porsche Greg yeah he's trying to
get me in Porsches and finally I was
just like I don't want to [ __ ] give a
[ __ ] about you so he gets deep into he
gets deep brother I know you well your
bro knows his [ __ ] cars
he kind of shat on Ferrari he's a hater
on Freddy but he's like a race purist
it's like know about McLaren right and
all that
Minoo was all about Porsche he's like
rap track time stuff like that also
known as a nerd track time yeah they
give me track pounds of never gonna get
the [ __ ] in my face it's so weird
go get your big dick in the shower get
the [ __ ] out of my face he look he's
looking good though I like his beard and
he's all thick yeah he doesn't a thick
beard he's got any thick are you are you
next
not this week but next week because my
shows are Embraer he's coming out here
via Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
Monday so I got Tempe this weekend
little make three Tempe improv 36-month
Saturday it's gonna be nice and cool for
either oh yeah and then next weekend
after that I think I'm free be cool yeah
they were flirting with me there's
thrillin sending me to Saudi Arabia and
I was like you know unless you're gonna
pay me crazy to bounce money I just
don't know if I can get on a plane and
go to Saudi Arabia for three shows for
real money but I just don't know if I
can do it you but Bram I would like to
come down there maybe one night yeah I
could do that if he's gonna be helpful
yeah you mean Jay I love your bro you
guys come to Braille
I like that Brennan I like that we were
in the limo in an old-school limo by the
way that belongs in the 80s with those
shitty the whole trip was the whole trip
was Neil Diamond that means really and
Brennan Brennan said something to the
effect of we were talking about killing
somebody with the bare hands and then
you go well I mean they stay there and
he goes I could ever be in this room
I can kill everybody in this room by
squeezing you and Jake no you could
never kill me by squeezing I squeeze and
you go you go no I could I could I could
you don't think I could squeeze you
around the ribs and kill you and Jay
goes I'm 230 pounds not a shot he's oh
that's because we were talking about a
man fighting some of the top and I'm a
women he's really picking the s if Jacob
eats shevchenko I said if he could just
take the shots and cover up and then get
a hold of her she's closer he's so
strong he's so strong grab her like you
ever seen and split when the guy grabs
old lady and goes
Jay could do that that every hunt and 15
pounder he could and then you said you
could do that to Jay
now I had got my hands around him which
I did get you did get your note though
and yeah I gave him 60% and his good you
picked him up I picked up and squeeze
pretty hard not fully cuz on my Gucci
shooting so what do you like this and I
could feel his back oh you could any
ghost that did feel good I want nothing
if I held that because he's gonna [ __ ]
his pants cuz he was going yeah it flex
really hard yeah and so you hell yeah
we catch in there so you think you could
do that to chin and me you guys yes
Janos two things to thank you for sure
you you could squeeze me until I [ __ ]
died yeah if I really went like that yes
I don't know yeah you'd break bones
eventually and you break down I don't
know man Wow [ __ ] [ __ ] and that was
chapter you kill cat I don't know you
did you a tapping practice yeah but if
you could you know do you have fun Vegas
cat how about we get there it's just the
four dudes we're going to eat talking
about cars and digs and cat asses and
check it out whatever anything I walk by
and Caicos you know what let me get out
of here I wouldn't get out you couldn't
gotten away from us fast enough I felt
so bad although og you don't wanna hang
out with the four where'd you go I ended
up walking up and down the strip I
haven't been back since I think I was in
high school so I just wanted to kind of
see everything go shopping and then it
got too hot so hot it was so hot I did
not wanna do anything if I hate walking
this room Jesus guy hey walk in that
[ __ ] stress about me you and Jay are
having a deep conversation about
politics and how things are changing and
finally Jay goes to get like the
sandwiches or something I look at you
know you can kind of Kauai and he goes
what are you guys talking about your
interest dude did you see the interview
last night on Trump no oh my god six
minutes have you seen your crevasse on
Icarus oh we get in current events when
we get to it it was so good Trump Games
homeboy access for like I don't know
three days of like behind the scenes Wow
Air Force one argued with them brought
collusion it was a maze are they talking
about the part where he the part where
he closer the well no the part where he
goes he goes you know so for foreign aid
or someone comes to you with information
on your opponent you're gonna do what
with you guys I love this about Trump it
just Cindy go Sam I'd probably listen
here's well no you should go the FBI yes
and this is come on who do you know the
FBI if so has information on your
opponent I know once he goes let's be
real so let's call up the FBI
who's almost see what the information is
it can help me great and then
it's that big of a deal Dental FBI yeah
because they used my dog so you don't
know where the information is coming
from maybe the information comes from
one of your aides it's not like you know
so so it's not like when a Russian guy
comes and gives you information they're
not like in a spy code like and listen
to me I want to give you some
information yeah
it's from Russia they don't do we got
this from our agents that's not how it
works they somehow you know an American
guy who gives you information you go
right really that's what it is a pile of
ultra the Russians didn't get him
elected
I love how John's kind of honest about
it though yeah cuz I'm gonna listen what
are you talking about
let me hear this it was really good do
something
why yeah you want to watch the whole you
know yeah little thing it's you know can
we what did you have it on that though I
saw I had a specific one that he let's
see it we're talking about it let's just
know it
so therapy is something I've been
recently doing and I used to make fun of
it me too there was nothing good to it
you're doing it yep and you know
therapists are very expensive and a lot
of times your insurance doesn't cover it
but well sometimes you can't go like
you're not time yeah but you know when
you talk to somebody who's been doing
this like a professional really knows
how to do it a counselor who's trained a
lot of times manikin truly helped in
there it definitely helped and now you
don't have to go to the therapist you
don't have to you just cut out a few
minutes here in there and I'm talking
about better help better help better
help will assist your needs and match
you with your perfect licensed
professional therapist yeah you can
start communicating the under 24 hours
that's it it's not a crisis line it's
not or self-help it's it's actually
professional counseling done securely
online and there but these guys have a
broad range of expertise it's better
better helps counsel network which may
not be locally available in many areas
but you can get to them with you know
online it's more affordable worldwide to
here's the big thing though it's
affordable it's way more affordable than
your traditional offline canceling and
final financial aid is even available
how about that visit better help calm
slash fighter and join the over 500,000
people taking charge of their mental
health right now and
an experienced professional and by the
way fighter and kid listeners get 10%
off your first month a better help.com
slash fighter get your hairline right
yes and it really is a great service and
it's I think it's an important one
better help calm slash fighter um
so oh my god so they're in the oval
office and he's asked him a question and
here's one of the guys that work for
Trump Trump in the middle in that you
hear the guy coughed in the middle it he
goes get out of here if you're gonna
cough just get out of yours one do it
again it's important the stood again
what's [ __ ] this is what's concentrated
me is ABC left that in like they could
edit that yes make them look bad not
that made him look bad then the press is
only interested in making them look what
he says he does it's just all this fake
juices so Harvey and they go why do you
why do you tweet news out why not and he
goes cuz I deal with the narrative
here's you guys only get news from me if
it's directly for me otherwise all made
up that's right so why would I wait for
someone do it I'd last out myself a
hundred percent carry on to you watch it
real quick yes parts whole there see now
tell you what he's intimidating here
imagine being what's the interviewers
name Stefan Avila 7op yes yeah they
usually don't like each other you work
for Clinton yes when you will see my
financial statement at some point I
assume it's going to be released you'll
be very impressed with the job we've
done much much bigger much much better
than anybody thereafter my financial
statement the Senate they'd like to get
my financial statement at some point I
hope they get it you're gonna turn it
over now at some point I might but at
some point up they get it because it's a
finality fantastic financial statement
it's a fantastic financial statement and
let's do that over he's coughing in the
middle of my aunt's yeah okay I don't
like that you know your chief escapee to
the COFF please leave Shana
no serious is there this can't you just
can't just to change the shot I'm sorry
okay do you want to do that a little
differently then yeah we just [ __ ] up
with it so at some point I'll how weird
is that he gives you access like what a
scumbag move an inch if you're a BC what
a scumbag [ __ ] gives you access and he
answers a listening I'm on the fence
about Trump I'm not the biggest
supporter I don't think I'm not a big
hater on him whatever right so but if
this interview and he gives you access
and then you should leave the press
loses credibility when they do this
because I had a pain yeah this whole
thing is like 60 minutes did a hit job
on Jordan Peterson they're comparing the
alt-right and stuff is like he's the
farthest thing from an alright guy you
know it's like well guys it'd be fair at
least at least read the book if you
disagree with somebody at least see what
they're saying it's [ __ ] you know I'm
not a fan of trumps but the way they
Huffington Post and CNN the way they
treat him is is just it's like you know
it's ballsy what he did he's answering
their trick question like who's going
after him - he was he was giving it to
them well the economy is doing very well
in a lot of areas right so it's like if
the Democrats don't figure out how to
get it together and they put Biden up
good luck it's a little thick weird
thing cuz Biden's leading the polls now
and that strapless with the voice George
so George asking us because they're in
Iowa and they get done with Trump's
speech she's with him during all this
like behind axis haven't seen any
president do this before and George
asked him is you know have you heard you
know you're behind in the polls in
trouble goes in what poll that what
polls it's fake polls that those aren't
real yeah and then again this should add
this but ABC just wants to ruin them he
goes to his chief guy whatever it goes
can we get the actual numbers on this
poll so we don't just go off word here
and then it turns out that he is behind
those polls but he's still just cute he
goes doesn't matter I haven't started
let me start my campaign exactly yeah
you guys I'm not too worried about it it
was interesting it was really interested
schools they show the Air Force one bad
thing is cool yeah and how he's like
there's a whole meeting room and there's
10 they're meeting on the plane ride and
then he's redone the the Air Force One
he's redone the colors it looks just
like his well I think they have like a
pod where the president if their planes
going down the president gets in it
George asked him that he goes is it true
like in that movie there's a pot and Joe
Trump goes there's some stuff we can't
talk about yeah that's the new one looks
like a USS you ups postal sir
yeah but it's kind of really
[Music]
that's a bummer that ABC did that though
have a little respect and a little bit
courtesy and like when you when you when
you make somebody look bad like that
it's just obnoxious edit that [ __ ]
[ __ ] did you guys this would be the
biggest ratings you've had in how long
and it's just because of him but it's
like I'm not even I'm not a fan of
Trump's but I see that I side with him
you know I'm saying like I don't know
picking on the guy it's like when you're
being petty
just let that let the facts lay where
they are and let me make up my mind stop
trying to make it but if you're George
it's like dude he's never getting George
Stephanopoulos should know better that's
very disapoint all he meant to do it for
sure
Wow so now will the Bible now you're
[ __ ] yeah few wins and whatever he's
the president 500 days from now you
think he's gonna do this again
it's very short-sighted and what do you
think that the Trump haters do you think
that helps anything no they they don't
need now you're not changing anybody's
mind it's like you're just drawing
stronger lines you know it's so
interesting yeah it was cool to watch
though wow it's really good yeah see
that tournaments though since we came
out already on it sure sure
is this it grant Paltrow explains why
she and her husband have said that it
I've heard of having separate homes
though I like that idea sometimes I
forget didn't know there's someone
really famous oh um
Roseanne Barr and it didn't work out but
Roseanne Barr and who was she made it
through Tom Arnold lived in separate
houses for a long time so like you do
[ __ ] together
yeah but then at the end of the night
Yoda intercept grips they're not on top
of each other makes sense because she
was basically getting [ __ ] from people
because she came out and said that her
and her new husband spent four days out
of the week together and then the other
three days they live in their own homes
I mean I I kind of like that I'd it's no
different being a comic though because
like I'm gonna know Thursday Friday
Saturday this week so my girl gets a
break three days a week from me it's
about time come home she misses me so if
I was on the road I think when you're
constantly together out there who you
are correct like me and Brian before
constant again I want to kill him
you want to kill me with your girl - out
get well-thought Kuya I eventually you
just anybody need your space may need
your space just to think you know yeah
just give give me some room
yeah [ __ ] I speaking of the road I was
watching a documentary on Joan Jett you
know about Joan Jett she was like the
first in a lot of ways the first female
rocker like the first woman to do see
you're young her biggest song yeah I
know crimson and clover or reputation
but she was like our famous most favored
here on the made it famous bad
reputation but Joan Jett was like the
first badass female rocker and she kind
of like assured in a whole new like
somebody young it was a pretty cool
documentary I didn't know not so close
it's crazy not so much all right her
influence was crazy I don't know the
road the road the road you know time
span our Road and just was like non-stop
[ __ ] when you're a musician god I am
beef and by the way you're in a bus sir
and this one made me think about it the
amount of time you spend together in a
band
no but how can you not they break up all
my god they said for the law a lot of
bands they don't even talk to each other
they don't like Metallica demon talk you
know the yacht stage they this they go
their separate they don't mean do you
need to because you're singing also
please keep in mind you're singing the
same songs over and over again I think
doing that so so Taylor Swift had been
on the road three hundred days like a
different city every day get the [ __ ]
out of here I would go crazy you know
who's the biggest touring artist hold on
hold on Chinn Dido I thought I'd take
his touring artist who made the most
money last year being a touring art okay
hold on now Taylor had a big ear huh
oh yeah I'll give you a Taylor had a big
year so uh so also I won't put any
specific order but two girls one guy two
separate girls once you separate get one
guy there's two girls top three [ __ ]
Beyonce yep oh I thought the band was
Beyonce it might be [ __ ] as crazy as it
sounds it might be Madonna ariana grande
come on Harry gave you the other Beyonce
Beyonce Taylor Swift Oh swept and then
you got forgot the dude ah [ __ ] it is it
Timberlake nope you should be out
figures onra Oh Justin Bieber nope he
took last year off remember you don't to
say the genre jay-z nope
ed Sheeran makes more money than oh yeah
ed Sheeran have you ever seen him enough
to [ __ ] on him though
well there's such [ __ ] not really
like you look in the grand scheme of
things just change it on him don't get a
negative [ __ ] on him I don't have a
negative no I'm just saying yeah great
some people do but but what he thought
when he did most success hatred he got
forget I don't like that stuff
but everybody was saying online they
were like on Game of Thrones are like
[ __ ] you guys will he's singing that
dumb song and [ __ ] and it was like it's
one of the most viewed so he's winning
yeah but he also sells out arenas yeah
really
he's friends with Charlemagne Sherman
was saying he's gonna make something
like 700 700 million dollars just stop
touring oh he's gonna be a billion it
just with that guitar Wow
sure you might copy some people [ __ ] who
cares I'll [ __ ] what do you want to
do sue me here's here's five million art
shut the [ __ ] I gotta be honest I don't
realize he's that big the Charlemagne
brought him up I had no idea that shit's
crazy but internationally he's so big
yeah ed Sheeran yeah you know the game
is national holiday we're in his
hometown and where did the [ __ ] spread
where I am so my good friend me said
he's a he's a red he said ginger good
for gingers everywhere oh I don't want
an inspiration for genders they can't go
out this doesn't have any social media
you know does it the people are so mean
to me just does not yeah that's messed
up you know cuz he's ugly he's not no
it's not hey let's call black here let
me see the judge of this counted hold on
relax
he's cute it's got a wide base wonderful
ah he's in God gave him the voice of an
angel okay but look at our deep I know
he's got a skis a ginger in I mean
gingers to [ __ ] that guy okay hold on
there artists are out there are girls
that like a red bush they'd like a fire
crotch I'm
saying he'd listen that's his word it's
not mine but he got off because there's
so much toxic on there oh wait I have a
billion dollars I'm off social media and
I'm selling tickets dude I would job so
she so what I get the [ __ ] off
I'd be out I wish I don't have to be on
that [ __ ] good for him kill it though
yeah kill it
yeah chance I really don't think he's a
bad looking guy he's right people make
fun of his eyes cuz it's like you know
the other opposite way not he's got fish
raw side is the lazy eye
gnarly nice yeah like chameleon he's got
cow eyes he can see he's he's sideways
[ __ ] he can jam out he's got why
he's just got a wide face but I don't
think he's terribly ugly
it was like that and then I mean he
could fix it it's okay it's lazy or for
just it's going another that be called
geyser there's a lazy out one it's a
smaller like you had some [ __ ]
Brenda's got new jokes on the Mexican
that being married to a Mexican woman
and you had a joke about give it away I
know I want you so badly is it really
funny okay but um yeah he's got a little
bit about a name for that they don't
matter boys killing it no I don't think
he's getting his Redbush sucked every
night yeah absolutely by like the
hottest girls on the plane that's a
hundred that's the way the world works
don't say red bush look it's got a red
dick but he's crazy you don't think he's
getting that [ __ ] Twizzlers sup he's
got a twizzler red Twizzlers probably
very red when it gets hard you know I
mean cuz I'm proud of him I celebrate
him here comes my red balloon here comes
my red balloon you know what's crazy
so let's say he was a chick with all
that money you could Kardashian it and
just like let me get a blow out some fat
ass titties and a lip job and you're
gonna figure it out if you're an ugly
dude you just sounds like yeah there's
no money I can fix it he's not ugly your
girls don't okay I'm not gonna change
you're gonna be you're gonna be a ginger
yeah you could supplied you you could be
you could be Jeff Bezos who did seem to
go on some testosterone and got a
stylist take a look at before and after
Jeff Jeff Bezos the
he's you know no Elon Musk destroys his
hundred-percent Elon Musk he was a total
dork Elon Musk was dork central what I
didn't see this picture I mean yeah see
and people say money to my happiness
look at Bezos it's just busting nuts now
his girl's a [ __ ] guy he was such a nerd
there look at that oh this is really no
God here - oh but just kind of he stole
I mean it's just uh
dude he's killing it now oh yeah he's
Marlon mirai's yeah I mean it is mr.
clean he looks like mr. pajetta and just
fat dick I bet and just billions and
billions of dollars man it's pretty
attractive - Jay richest man in the
world and his wife is what six now
richest richest woman in the world yeah
uh go go - go - Elon Musk before and
after I think his is worse he was a
solid - neither he's a 10 green
flamethrowers and she's a big boy I've
seen him in person he's a big guy he's
probably six four very tall big south
hat come on bro look at the hair he said
he timepiece now got a great [ __ ]
that hair transplant dude dude he looks
amazing that she's why didn't mind take
like that Wow dude he looks like you and
Jeremy Piven in the middle there when
you guys before you guys that here look
at him there he looks like an alien
there but there he looks big brain check
out the big brain on my rad yeah you
know I good old good-looking is he a
good other typing I wouldn't get crazy
but he's not a good-looking guy he's a
big my Billy my wife is very attracted
to him so a lot of women women he gets
wherever he wants
he's a very easy brilliant guy he's very
he's tall he's not bad-looking dude
now he's broad he's a big guy he's come
up was better than anyone's yeah yeah he
didn't look that that's a hair that's a
great hair transplant I'll tell you that
much yep that's a [ __ ] well done his
hope for people out there man yeah well
my wife told me to get my eyes done she
says you should get your eyes sunny you
know she did she goes look you can't
really see what your eyes are and she
goes like if I was like this and she
goes she pulls her eyes on yes would you
would you like me I just stop that I was
like don't don't push your eyes all the
way down where I can't get my eyes done
be I'm just gonna get my I'm just gonna
get a little hug you've been talking
about for a while I just I I'm not gonna
do it I'm too lazy but I just gonna do
it I'm intrigued by the idea of getting
a lid I tell everyone if you did it
don't
first of all I'll tell everybody I'm not
gonna be the guy who's running around
acting like look at that though there
you go you kidding that's a big
difference fine both ways you know I'm
gonna be I'm gonna look good
I need a lid tuck come on dude give me
your endorsement see that you don't you
want to see why why does that I grow
over like it's hereditary my mother has
it - do you not want to see and so does
my dad do you don't you wanna see you're
in the box and your eyes - you put some
injections there yeah but yeah here's
the thing you do it every six months I'm
not doing that well I'll never get rid
of them regular hair no bags
chin eyelids I don't have lids so there
you have nothing there's nothing no wow
there's nothing there's no lid it's
literally he's like just closed yeah you
like your Volkswagen bug he's a long
time
he's like a Korean man he's a book
jacket that's pretty sight he's like a
Korean or all Koreans like that no my
brother has lids my whole family does
suffer me you have very small lids I
have none here hey did some guy here
you're when I'm in shape of them a
little better but why aren't you getting
in shape I don't understand Coney Robins
maybe I can what else we got hit us a
neck secure a sponsor for like a
facelift and [ __ ] no there's a guy
there's a guy you got a one guy you
don't want to deal on you don't [ __ ]
get it they're gonna get a deal on a
funky bastard or the real thing go to
the this is my eyes looking permanently
was surprised Oh that'd be great like I
put my [ __ ] finger in a socket to pay
money for that death so do you guys
remember the snapchat filter that I
showed you guys a couple weeks back
where it turns you into a girl yeah so a
20 year old college student he's a male
used that filter to make himself look
like a girl he then put
picture out onto tinder and he guised
his age as nineteen he had this
gentleman slide into his messages and
they started talking they moved to
another social media platform where he
said oh I'm not nineteen I'm actually 16
years old so he's pretending to be a 16
year old girl he found he took
screenshots and sent them to the police
department and they found out that the
guy who was messaging this underage girl
was actually a police officer in San
Mateo so now the officer is actually on
investigative leave he's getting paid
and they're trying to investigate
whether or not the messages are real or
fake god he was I was just looking to
get someone just ha the only thing is
you think if you think they're 19 and
you're talking to them 19 is legal the
conversation go when he said 16 it went
to snapchat and they ended up messaging
there and he said oh I'm actually 16
years old I'm not 19
tinder won't let me be on the platform
if I say that I'm 16
oh but they found each other a little
[ __ ] up kids what depends what how
he's judge what she goes oh my bad I'm
actually 16 it feels like that's all
good baby we'll figure it out like what
he must got pretty yeah even when she
said like can I ask you this maybe he's
again there there is a big difference
between taking action and talk I agree
and it's also on mine it was just
genuine yeah and you're just Aaron and
she looks 19 you thought she was 19 yeah
you know that 16 also like I do I know
what's a kid and everything else the
smart thing to do is go see yeah but
this is I don't know man it sounds a
little bit very it sounds like you're
ruining somebody's entire life and their
entire career based on sort of a
slippery kind of like well you find
yourself yeah a little [ __ ] for just
talk it's a little fun I don't like it
yeah the 20 year old college student
said that when he told the officer that
he was 16 he ended the officer messaged
him back saying are you ready to have a
good time this weekend and that's when
the messages got explicit so if the
messages are real and that's what
actually happened then the officer full
well knowing the
sixteen year old no I'm not I'm not
gonna do it I'm just saying how you
defending this guy
I mean well sixteen is legal in some
states is it steady state no Vegas
seventeen Vegas is sixteen no though 79
America Brian was she 16 a half defend
this travel but does she turn 16 this
turn Sam what did you know this the beer
when did she turn 17 is the question I'm
asking if she turned 17 by the weekend
and they were is this guy
it does not say he's 52 look like he's
younger just got my face young - I bet
he's 28
yeah a good-looking guy I mean you're
off today I'm good looks you know okay
well you want to suck Elon Musk's Tom
post-post hair operation you're off
today endless job who has guys done what
else you got it back so you brought up
that the Chernobyl series on HBO is good
right
what the best series ever see a lot of
people agree with you and there were a
bunch of Instagram models or aspiring
Instagram models who went to turn ovals
horse and decided to hold up so no look
at this how dare you about Brendan take
it easy she's in a new killer suit it
just fell off her not all of them are
like this but all Russian girl you could
have their hottest [ __ ] Russian all the
radiation I'd still get hot as [ __ ]
Russian girls dude Russia puts it out
so does Romania so oh sure no bullsháá
Knobble liberals who aren't Russian are
traveling to Chernobyl specifically I'll
go back to that one but that's not at
the shirt that shirt on the beach she's
a 10 but why is she on here cuz she
shuts her below cuz she's bitter sir
just a little more fish
Oh what's this radiation on my tits
whoops they grew way bigger Jerrod hold
on keeps she's eating water who maybe
Chernobyl made her naughty there she is
right there who all this radiation makes
me nah what stirred what's their
captions I've bet they're capsules this
one right here
uh go down she's on a swing and she says
babushkas of Chernobyl mm-hmm Bush
grandmother yeah Russian why did she say
grandmother Chernobyl I don't know maybe
because all this radiation makes me want
a saw and this girl is walking barefoot
I know well if your dick is pulsing if
your dick is radioactive oh wow
apparently the radiation got no feet
looks like it that's why I shouldn't
walk barefoot in a radioactive [ __ ]
place and what did she say nothing no
come on man the captions are my favorite
oh oh she's definitely for nothing
either mm-hmm oh there there she's
getting straight to the point I need to
go this tiny difference I need to go
rescue them from Chernobyl oh let's put
on say so myself you have managed too
much radiation at all
scroll inch in the hood they're just
screenshots how but what was her home so
there's no one one for mercy begin me
radiation really blows your ass how does
this radioactive man mm-hmm-hmm
I got a little Chernobyl in my pants
when do nudes oh oh here comes my
nuclear reactor Oh this nuclear reactors
about the bomb I'm gonna get some cold
water
oh cool my rift [ __ ] terrible jokes
so we get ourselves we're coming up with
it I can't go get a site Iran we don't
get a scientist in here how about my
Nobel style oh man you know what let me
put some ice in my mouth and help ya
know I don't know I didn't want your
nuclear rod I don't want the nucleosome
these someone needs to cool down this Y
on nuclear I don't like Chernobyl Oh
I'm about to blow like Shinobu
I don't want your old mouth cool
specialized yo your gates no no you got
a rod on there and I don't want her to
baulkham spew radioactive lava
everywhere Waffle House man why we're
doing our little turn no politician
Nobles how about the Chernobyl girls ah
how about how about how scientists let's
suck ah dude how about we have our own
little game of Chernobyl know where your
like my [ __ ] rod is radioactive and
I'm like yeah armor sure doctor no no we
list some idea what it's a Chernobyl
porno okay the girls of Chernobyl right
I'm the scientist we don't want my road
we don't want my rod to buff no and it's
kind of unless they're dressed up like
the scientists in there yes and I put on
a wig and I know no I don't know I'm
trying I want to be a movie you know
you're eyeing up the guy fighting this
weekend Cox what's his name who's the
guy fighting in bare-knuckle the ball
dakota cocker Cochran there's a gay porn
star fighter yeah hey hold on before he
was slit Seamus man's name he did some
gay porn before he started fidon't
Karen's ashamed of it but it's not it's
not like so Bri exchange in show Brian I
know this is gonna just show behind no
co-pays shame hey no it's just a little
like it's a this is so going look would
you do this it's not like real gape all
right let me say just look hey Kat let
me read the situation in did he did he
have bills to pay
correct it was bills was he setting
himself through school detention old
school nurse seems like well maybe he
had the idea to do he had the idea to do
it so that's him just so you have an
idea dude
all right fine you're Malik endeared
right he's a stud this guy's a super
stud hit it chin okay one second right
now hold on hold on before you do it cuz
I'm 40 before you sold on this men are
you saying how gay is it yeah so it's
what the level like it like a job they
were wrestling and things got a little
out of control
whoa
talking like so they were talking it's
complement of a speedo no here we're
talking jiu-jitsu with your shirts off
with your boys okay and then I'm Sam
Sheridan he's somewhere in the middle
okay so yeah all right we're talking
what a prey sure enough he's so gay
Sam Sherratt the singer Sam shortens our
friend Patti's hot what's the seams in
Jared sure no no no this is Sam Sam
Smith so there's jujitsu with your pants
off with your buddy sweaty Sam Smith
okay he's in the middle all right so
there's the Rose ball can I wear a dress
yeah and there's the gay parade all
right so we're in the middle he's in the
middle hit it Jo
I don't care let me see this what is so
clear on the throne information click on
the third one inch in okay so he's he's
he's did some film he did some ground
impounding okay
can I be honest with you I [ __ ] I
love him you're a gay man there's
nothing I love that he either we have a
gay porno he's not gay he said he only
did it to pay the bill yeah look at me
he's ashamed oh he's not gay no I'm not
looking at another pictures let me see
what else you do so I got my circle one
inch in hold on don't go to that one
again and then these fake though that's
not that's gotta be someone else you
don't know they're not fake Brian really
did it yeah he's talking about
interviews
dude that's just two guys open guard
jack off on each other no the next one
chin just keep going yeah let me see
what working
[Music]
there's no way could you sometimes you
get stuck in a tough situation
yeah and do you do all the work in the
club do can you work at 9:00 to 5:00
right or can you stick one in the ass
that's a little a little awesome well I
think sexuality is complicated well
that's what you it's a joke let's see
that's just that posing oh no see that's
fine till your legs right
all these girlfriend hey what do they
even call that what do you call that
okay we're good trunks and but obviously
trunks and bucks
look man that's dude oh sure cuz that
daddy's [ __ ] looks like Carolyn he's
a little grey it's called the fight of
the kid porn oh he's a little grey oh
listen you can take it off whenever you
want okay thanks but but but I scroll
down ah damn it but um he I still say I
still say I like I love this embrace it
[ __ ] it
no of course he's not he's not embracing
it because we're in such it we live in a
very you know I mean in this in the
business of MMA it's a very not even
homophobic it's just there's no there's
not a lot of gay people and Oprah in the
world it's not embraced what are you
talking about even Hollywood yeah it's
not what but you know what he kicks ass
he [ __ ] guys and kicks out in my book
in my book I [ __ ] love him
Brett like that to me is like I can't
wait to watch it yeah but how was he as
an MMA fighter let's look at his record
he's had I mean there's a lot of fights
his [ __ ] had a lot of fights
he's the real deal so watch your mouth
with him 32 and 13 I'm not I'm not
making fun of this guy 32 fights holy
[ __ ] 32:13 yeah he's won a shitload of
fights he was in I think it was just on
the Ultimate Fighter he was
Ultimate Fighter impressive maybe one of
he's in Bellator uh I think they talked
a little bit about it I did Dana there
if you go back this interviews that
where Dana brought it up and he lost to
James Vick right constable hold your
head high
[ __ ] that who cares he's awesome Cochran
hold your head high Brian's coming that
is a name how about but but I mean so
what he's that's his name
god bless I'm rooting for that dude
thirty-two fights no joke signed
bare-knuckle this weekend because Holly
fights right so he's fighting Chris
Leben right because leavin yeah Wow
I'll watch the [ __ ] out and you know
what I'm gonna root for him [ __ ] all
sorts in firing to get roots for him
what what what's his first love Bryan
Toder does uh Dakota [ __ ] Kota Cochrane
great name by the way
that's not his porn name no only did one
though right let me see he performance
sixteen videos okay under the name Danny
okay I don't give a [ __ ] I love him
sixteen porno videos that's a full life
dude he's that's a full life if he was
if he had done K if he had done regular
porn we'd all be like yeah say good they
did gay porn I don't give a [ __ ] I think
they're just making because he's saying
that he's not gay
he's just did it for money you know what
I blame ya I don't play I'm sure it's
I'm sure he was a young dude and it's
you nobody's proud of all the things you
did as a kid tagging um so I've had some
issues with money and I I would never do
so no I I like his attitude and he's a
gay man and there's nothing wrong with
that and I like that you defend him and
I'm also gonna watch him and root for
him as well
I played again I've had some financial
struggles I would never do gay porn it
was there was a thing he did it was a
misstep it's probably attracted an ideal
or he's into both yeah might be bi
probably but he did 16 gay videos you
know so it's not like I was a career for
a while that'd be a career it was a
choice he made unless you got not get
like sixteen in them well anyway some
people call it college for fine it could
be it could be 60 dudes in a month
yep that's college perfectly possible
your freshman year lost you know it is a
major did something you don't want and
you're young you're short-sighted maybe
it was fighting who knows again wagon so
I fought when I was younger and I never
make it ever tagged him out okay so I
see where you're going with this
and I want to just let all this as no
yeah no like it's a fine line yeah it's
a fine that's not the line
most guys go what wait does he fight at
55 wait and welterweight is much bigger
than that okay
it's 5/8 that's a dick Conor not the
biggest thumb Hannah go back to the
pictures okay the one in his ass is
bigger okay yeah move on well I want
this to be known we're rooting for him
yes we are
I would definitely watch his fight for
railroad I like the guy next one so last
week a graph went viral somebody made a
graph of Leonardo DiCaprio's age and the
age of ever girl he's ever dated since
gizelle and it shows that he's never
dated somebody over the age of 25 and
people lost their minds why yeah exactly
hold on hold on are we gonna pretend are
we gonna pretend that older guys
unattractive to younger girls and I'm
not saying 16 but 22 and older I'm sorry
is that not when women are most
attractive and guys who are in position
of power is that not what they want this
time it's his all this time I had to be
shitty about it but you show a normal 40
year old their normal 22 year old 99.9
the guys said for my boy Cochran are
gonna pick for you to pick the younger
girl that's the way life is and also I
don't make him a bad guy and also those
are women there are women come on let's
go through the list you [ __ ] gizelle
right Tom Brady's grown us sure bar
Rafael Blake Lively ever heard of her
and then the rest is really hot girls
usually said that the best-looking women
on the planet dude he's a yourself
because the best everybody would flip
out he gets so out of shape in between
seven roles big it's been awesome yeah
yes your seam on the sucking yachts seen
him and Percy go
seen in person had t-shirt with a belly
no he's autistic and and and yes every
25 everybody tion 5 - who cares yeah and
by the way in 99 he was that age so he
was dating he was very young in 99 he
was that age he was fired dating girls
his age he was yet one day he's 19 so
he's gonna go for the older girl but I'm
saying now that he's 44 a 21 year old 20
year old for my finger just be mentally
challenging but they you know they gonna
be into the same things but but but
bring up coming over you know your mom
busting Nazi bro bring up that's what
you're about Camilla Monroe knee first
ever heard of her now let's take a look
like painfully hot you think let's let's
take a look hmm that's interesting
okay but she's that doesn't make my dick
jump out of my G yeah hey you know what
I feel guilty she's a teenager okay
have you seen her naked or you know
she's terrible why would you want to
kiss her
she's a full-grown woman too by the way
so that these are haters these are
people that just don't like seeing yeah
that's weak I celebrate Leonarda kappa
thank dude i can't tell you the last
time i've been more excited for a movie
then once upon time in hollywood i can
movi what oh is that is that what bro is
that the tarantino yes sir i hear it as
good as pulp fiction I heard yes Stan
ovation standing ovations about gonna
beast man let me see it can I see the
trailer you know what move you can't
play it ok I can't but no we don't we
get kicked off please we keep thinking
pictures yeah we don't need pictures
they separate movies they look awesome
but I love that since drama to paint
Gaylor Canyon I'm sewing oh it's all
about the Tatum Hollywood again though
in the murders tape um you know what
movie I heard is actually the best movie
of the year you're in it right the Joker
mmm yeah GameChanger I did I did looking
for a street told me the word on the
street is Oscar I I did I did that I saw
somebody told me awesome it might be the
best joke anyone's ever seen yeah Heath
Ledger says hold by Viking yeah
okay well listen I think it's gonna be
iconic cats oh and I got it I heard it
did you see like like yeah okay yeah I
heard it hold my oxycotin hold might
look at that
I think someone painted that it no no
that's the scene I'm in see what he's
doing there
really yeah that's it awesome scene that
looks like an awesome since I seen a man
can't wait dude uh-huh what else we got
chin let's see
chef tell the owner kappa dude posture
not lost your reverent nuts dude
bust them hey catch me if you can yeah
me yeah no not you leo
I thought you were gonna but I thought
you're gonna have a turnover on your pal
homo oh this thing's about to blow we
have some problems you're acting real
weird since those Kaufman pictures I
don't I knew okay but not scary dude I
see I'm tryin if you can do it us I'm
trying to just help you out because
you're about to have a chore noble in
your pants you have to you know you have
to cool down the rods right you don't
know this the rods are very hard line
you have to flush it with ice water dude
that actually that's a pick-up line what
does everyone seen Chernobyl heat go up
girl be like seen Chernobyl soon as the
annual my rod is hot my rod is hot yeah
you and then hopefully the reference
otherwise she's gonna call the cops you
got a cold mouth let's see we got to
figure it out yeah see what have mr.
Noble
yeah figure yep let me figure it out
here it goes
Kaufman style oh boy it's a [ __ ] min
Cochran
[ __ ] you Dakota coffee but your favorite
friend my favorite fire dude to see how
she we should buy teeth if not we should
make him teeth make oh what's your what
Dakota Cochrane
mm-hmm 100% well something like that
never you do something with them it's
not a ton of fights yeah dude he's gonna
be Johnny Hendrix right or did he lose a
Johnny Hendrix hey I don't think he beat
Johnny Hendrix
it's no joke I'd say keep scrolling down
it's gonna be in another it won't be his
MMA
they thought up he losta james vague oh
[ __ ] here on Donnie Hendrix they're
knuckle TKO punches beep Johnny and get
out of here that's no joke
I'm in real Deezer everybody shut the
[ __ ] up
well I don't think anyone's making fun
of him breath I hope no time man he just
did not beat Johnny him alright
beautiful I'm sure the gay porn doesn't
help his great you know maybe that's the
reason for it does like in a way like
we're talking about people were talking
about big time when it first came out so
listen it seems like he only did one
fight maybe to get in the house and he
lost but that [ __ ] down that's all that
[ __ ] dies down right doesn't it you
can't porn really never goes away it
doesn't go away but like once it's out
and we know it Nats all she can do I
agree like no yes news keep what it
doesn't define her the [ __ ] the guy you
know is a phase of 16 yeah video for
shoot days and then he moves off then
you move on yeah we're talking about and
we're fans correct what else we're at
all right got this so a four year old
boy in Minneapolis actually used his
great Grandpa's Walker to grab the keys
off of a hook he then proceeded to get
in the car drove 10 to 15 miles per hour
to his favourite convenience store to
get candy he knocked down all those
bucket what actually made it in onto the
road he didn't hit anybody however
before he pulled into the road he hit a
tree and a mailbox on his way there but
he was not hurt he actually made it to
the convenience store holy [ __ ] and then
police found this little kids a badass
yes no mission impossible oh that's
super impressive so cute.i kids probably
go on and do some cool [ __ ] agree or rob
banks but I assume does cool [ __ ] or the
other yeah that's really cool man it's a
gutsy I can't imagine my kids 3 1 year
away imagine him behind the wheel you
know I cannot not since that's insane
that kids off the same thank God he's
safe
what else we get makes me nervous that's
a reference got this this little update
on David Ortiz
so as six people arrested we called it
side piece and it's supposed to be some
sort of like really highly calculated
scheme to to kill them but you know they
don't know exactly right yeah they do
though
classes being nice having sex with the
drug dealers show drug the cartel member
he's I'm sex with his girl and then you
know who at the at the hospital where
they're doing surgeon just found this
out when Sir John him his other side
piece and the cartel side piece start
fighting in the hospital while his wife
was on the way dude
big papa good did the the media is doing
him a favor by not blasting this out
that's pretty well known and it was two
guys so the cop the one right that there
whooping his ass no in the cut later and
yeah there's only eight thousand dollars
to kill Big Papi oh there you go and
that more the first guy was getting beat
up like crazy that guy was actually just
the getaway driver the other guy took
off on foot the guy that actually shot
him - that's him we're right yeah that's
him David Ortiz he's in Boston now that
he's safe yeah man
that's kind of crazy definitely [ __ ]
cartel members girls they're you know
she might be hot do we have a picture of
her if you're gonna risk your life is
Big Papi I bet she is just delicious I
have no doubt aryen stay stay low stay
on the DRF i if I'm an American and
generally well you are Dino also though
there's not a lot of you kill a national
hero a baseball here you think I do a
white gringo yeah but I'm saying when
you do that it's like you I feel like
that guy the people that tried to kill
him my public enemy number one period to
everybody we tough to get to the cartel
member well I see a cartel member just a
drug dealer who's he's a car he's a
big-time yeah well just get this news
from the cartel stuff Oh Jenna I got it
from in fact I got the I got all of it
from one of the oh don't say it then if
it's yeah it's pretty well know somebody
who knows yeah
well and knows David Ortiz name is Pedro
Martinez alright this is just a little
tidbit about that once upon a time movie
Quentin Tarantino wouldn't let them have
cellphones and made actors I would they
would get fired that's what they said
dude I love just
talking to our boy Marshall when I was
on set shooting that many of them he
went you know what's frustrating man he
goes in acting like you gotta be you
know be present here's the promise now
everyone's on their phones so they do
their and then they're on their phones
yeah that's right and I told him I I'm
saying this just to squint do this I
mean you know I would do I go I'd do a
no phone policy on set no for when we
break during your lunch break and resume
but I dunno phone policy yeah that's
exactly what I do yep everyone's on the
phones man yeah everybody I think that I
think it does take away from it
definitely does well where were we when
they wha
was it hilarities they did the no phone
they put your phones in bags yeah it was
awesome once some of the best shows I've
had they take your phones Rogan does
that all shows now Kevin Hart does it
but didn't they say like without problem
with that as people when they want to
use their phone they have to walk out
and you don't matter I do it in Denver
they've been doing it forever does you
put your phone in a in a case and it's
the best crowds in the world because
they're so focused on you it's the
greatest San Quentin has got no cell
phones on set none you're fired cell
phone out done you're going home I love
that Wow your hands you know what else
you have
how about all right so the u.s. women's
soccer team was criticized because of
how they celebrated gets their win
against Thailand did you see this engine
alright so they're just you know there's
because they completely blew them out of
the water right and this is a team
that's not really known for being you
know that great so they what they should
have this should've gotten light on them
yeah they broke a bunch of records
here's a nice level of soccer in the
world for women and you're mad that they
beat the [ __ ] out of the other high
level team I wanted to see what this
team looked like - it's not a picture of
them but check it out most goals scored
by a team and woke up a world cup of
match largest margin of victory most
goals scored by a player yeah okay who
date who who'd they beat there's a team
right here yeah get better check out the
dude in the back left get better what
are we talking about who gives a [ __ ]
yeah it's a World Cup level they should
have scored 20 on your dumbass
a life lesson that's true get better get
better get better I agree with you
by the way how about the the your
brother told me that the men's 15 and
under the boys 15 and under national
soccer team in America beat the Women's
World Cup team five to nothing
that was 15 and under Wow yeah cuz they
were talking oh why don't women though
real yeah well Jay will play what make
that up yeah why don't women get why
don't women not get paid as much more
good value market values - shut the [ __ ]
up that's why but like Michelle Williams
Michelle Williams talking about she
didn't talk about how you know the glass
ceiling and how equal pay and zoom like
that Michelle Williams who didn't get as
much as Mark Wahlberg for doing ADR said
the five shots mark nobody knows you
nobody knows you I don't know you I'm
never going to a movie for you I mean
you'll see guys on pornos complaining
you see my boy Johnny Cochran complains
because the guys get the guys less money
than the hot whatever the Marcus market
but that's worth in that in that woman's
in soccer men the market values higher
in porno women are higher you'll see
guys going this is ridiculous man we're
underpaid you're a dick yeah you just a
dick in a but you're a Marxist what else
we got Jen I think that's all I mean you
know about the Anthony Davis thing
yesterday yeah excited for Coke what
about you guys want to talk about Cuba
Gooding jr. and all yeah you saw it no
you can see this just for touching but
do we have the surveillance this is the
surveillance
oh this is it it was all up on her I
mean people so you got arrested for this
fun
you'll see what he does here that's his
chick that's his chick that's his girl
yeah and then the other girl comes over
nothing wrong with that
okay this is it all that sounds like an
Aladdin that's the only critique here
uh-huh
accused her let me see her and then he
puts his hand on her thigh that's it
that's it yeah but I mean and he got
arrested she's the one that made the
complaint Wow
and then right now it seems like
according to her he was touching her
breasts well then he kissed her hand
right there
yeah it's hard to see and then this guy
comes through who's this cop it's one of
his buddies I think he's gyrating his
hips his buddies yeah I think I think
it's all he goes to pour any goes to
jail for this no no he's he's gay you
got accused so he had to do himself in
he had to do that you know a beer thing
that is some [ __ ] maybe they're
swingers though I mean he touched his
buddy's crotch - oh it's all [ __ ]
his buddy pressed every dick every day
there's people with the real problem she
just kidding she just get his face here
she's she does later what'd she say I'm
uncomfortable ah she tries to go where
he's sitting with his chick at on a
different side of the bar and then she
was trying to do this but then he just
walked away
well she sounds it's a Kirti one let her
in seems like she's drunk and an [ __ ]
who's that now that's his chick oh yeah
what a crock of [ __ ] what bar is this I
don't know
TGI Fridays there - Friday Magic Hour
rooftop lounge in New York City also
known as Friday
so wait mcusic so this is the part where
she tries to complain god there's
nothing going on this is boring nothing
happened like like exactly so there's
year now oh wait this is just a
different angle
all right I can't watch this no it's not
the same bar Mista stuff makes me look
at so that's the accuser right there get
a [ __ ] life which one the one that's
walk in get out of there though
so that's the security she's complaining
to him that he touched inside of my leg
something like that and then she's
trying to get there and then he's not
letting her do you think you got
problems try being Terry she's just
being an [ __ ] whatever ya means
listen should he have grabbed inside of
her leg no should his whole crochet
what's happenin here
this is him just leaving he's hammered
huh he's definitely been sippin for sure
so you just I just to look at him he
probably is just touching her believe in
Punk he's wearing some weird be cool out
here she's just an [ __ ]
he's draw we don't know what what the
hell's going on but it didn't seem like
a lot how his video sucked yeah that's
all the video come on what are you doing
I got to close mine yeah that's what
happened dude you get to himself in
that's what I'm saying it's such
[ __ ] that could happen to anybody
dude [ __ ] you that's why only fist-bump
he's a really nice guy
only fist bump only fist bump she's got
it chin that's it [ __ ] what an
[ __ ]
what an [ __ ] speaking of [ __ ]
I'll be in Calgary Thursday Friday
Saturday this Thursday Friday Saturday
all shows almost sold out get tickets
now I just released my comps as well
Thursday Friday Saturday t fat k calm
next week I'm in Brea Brian cow might be
stopping by do a quick set for me that's
true I'm gonna bring some other friends
so Brea next week that is June 27
through 29th and then just announced
Cincinnati and Indy and that is in July
get your tickets now but Calgary I will
see you this week Brad next week t fat K
calm Brian you're going to temp it happy
tim pant ambien Bravo xx 21 22 I'm cool
as rods off oh yeah come cool Miraz off
1300 Saturday cool no I don't want you
to cool my rod dude then I got spokane
the 11th and 12th to 13th spokane they
need to take care of Washington you take
an uber and go up to my my my put my
spot
okay coeur d'alene you like to Spokane
loved it okay favorite clubs I'm all
over it I can't wait then I got San
Francisco College aligned 19 20 20 1920
speaking of rods San Francisco Cobb's
july 2019 and 28 it's
tak calm
said it dude that's right Brendan get
your rod out of my face this the fun kid
now